that's good to see this morning monica
how you doing all right doing great and
john i am so happy about my next guest
you know i love getting the backstories
of people who are like the backbone of
las vegas steven lee
has teamed up with some of the biggest
names on the las vegas strip now you've
no doubt heard his music and not even
known that it was
he and his bandmates making the moves
and the grooves to some of the funkiest
sounds
and biggest headliners here in las vegas
steven lee is joining us this morning
stephen thank you so much how you doing
i'm doing great how you doing mom i am
doing so good and like during commercial
break folks steven said hey monica you
know this is early for
for art it's performing they don't get
up at old dark 30 so we really
appreciate you being here
stephen tell everybody how long you've
been performing on the strip and some of
the big names that you've been
performing with
well i moved here from detroit as a
matter of fact
my hometown yeah right um
i moved here in 78 and uh i had a group
playing in the lounges here at
reno tahoe atlantic city band was called
friends
and uh i've been very very fortunate
yeah
to work with some great musicians some
great acts
i've played the last 11 years with don
and maria at the flamingo
hello still doing a series of symphony
dates with marie
nice it's um
it's great to have a diversity of acts
that you can work with i just did a date
up in north dakota with a
progressive rock group called asia yeah
very cool music um i have a recording
studio that you may be able to see in
the background
yeah just a little bit it's funky back
there i like it
oh yeah i got all my guitars on the wall
and produce
things for other people yeah i've done a
lot of work with uh king harrison who
has been the percussionist with neil
diamond for the last
135 years yeah right hey stephen i want
to jump in here because like i said you
know you've been doing this for a long
time and i love getting
you know that wisdom for a lot of the
up-and-comers here in las vegas so aside
from the obvious
what impact did the pandemic have on the
musicians up and down the las vegas
strip how are you guys feeling it and
how did you survive
well obviously uh it was devastating
because all of our work just went away
yeah
fortunately for me and my wife brenda
who is a wonderful keyboard player
um we do have this studio so we were
able to continue doing sessions for
people
creative projects did not stop
the live music however did and
um in in this business over the years
i've learned that
in order to survive especially in
situations like this one
the more diversified your your skill set
is the more you have a possibility of
maintaining some income see that's why i
wanted you on the show because i love
what you just said that is a huge piece
of wisdom right there
diversify what you do what are you most
excited about now that we have a sense
of
you know how to slow down the spread of
the pandemic even though a lot of people
aren't doing it but we have a sense of
it
uh how do you how do you think you're
going to move forward with this
in addition to the diversification right
well it's um it's still kind of a
close-knit community as far as the
musicians here in town
and we all support one another we all
love one another it's a brotherhood
so uh i'm i'm thankful that
the gigs are coming back uh just i've
been doing a bunch of tour dates uh
recently
and it's old home week everyone has
missed one another
yeah and we we're we're happy to see
households get back on their feet uh as
i said for me
and my immediate family we fared
pretty well because of the capacity to
do different types of things
related to music and music production um
i actually in a kind of a
strange sense enjoyed the shutdown
because i was able to just hunker down
in the studio
yeah focus on writing you know with he
had no distraction
so in a very self-indulgent way it was
kind of
cathartic for me not so for many of my
younger
compatriots many of whom lost their
homes
yeah bankruptcy uh so
it's been devastating and it is it is a
very hopeful time right now we see
things returning
and to address another aspect of your
question i think
the practices of good hygiene
should be something that we observe
anyway all the time
very good so yes yeah go ahead i'm sorry
to cut you off i'm just about out of
time real quick i got less than 30
seconds tell everybody
what you're going to be doing on the las
vegas trip coming up because you're
still with donnie and marie but i know
you do
things outside of that too right that's
right that's right i also work with a
group called
the pop strings orchestra nice i know
those guys
yeah yeah dave perriko and those guys
there are there are a couple of uh
exciting things
looming on the horizon they're not
they're not nailed down yet so i
probably shouldn't
say exactly what it is but um
fortunately there's a lot of work in
restaurants and nightclubs and things
like that
as i said marie is kind of getting back
on her feet with all of her symphony
dates she's talking about
touring new zealand australia okay uk
singapore that's gonna be cool that is
gonna be so cool stephen i am out of
time but
once again thank you i just wanted our
viewers to get a sense of somebody who's
been on the strip for a long time
you guys are the backbone of the strip
so thank you for all you do
you and all your fellow musicians on the
las vegas strip
take care and i appreciate you joining
me this morning all right love you
monica
all right have a good one again folks if
you're seeing donnie marie
that's the music you hear this man right
here stephen lee in the stephen lee
group
hey folks don't forget to catch the moj
show facebook
live tonight at 7 p.m we'll replay the
interview
i love the nuggets of wisdom that people
give i learned so much here
in las vegas